so
for our public that's here
um hi public everybody should have three
sheets here right here uh there's one
which has the agenda on it and and uh
there's another one that is the uh
minutes of what we did at the previous
meeting that was on March 27th and
there's another sheet which shows it's
it's addresses the issue of civics
education
um I thought today looking at our agenda
that
um
we have a number of issues on our plate
here we specifically have the ed306
rules which we've been looking at that
and I'd like to have a a discussion on
those as well then we also have on
number five on that agenda Civics
education and I put that on the scene
that has been approved in hb2 now the
one million dollars to develop a
textbook on Civics education K through
12.
and I wanted folks to know exactly where
the statutory language that we have in
place right now in New Hampshire law
came from
and it came from the state of Ohio and I
I have the Civics education uh uh format
and formula everything they have in Ohio
and apparel is exactly what we have we
put in the statute here and we'll I'll
explain all that mental health is
another issue that's which I think is a
very important issue in the state right
now
and
we're looking at
um
input from our school districts that it
seems to be a topic that's uh explosive
that we have number of students which
are displaying
health issues and we have three bills
which we have retained in-house
education regarding that topic and
whether the the concern that I'd like to
talk about today on that one is
um where do we place that we place it if
we do something with it in 193e under
adequacy or under studies or as a part
of Health and Wellness uh that that's a
conversation which we might be able to
get some sense of direction on then I
have under seven other and I like to do
right now is does everybody know
everybody up here at the table
you're good with that all right so I
like to approve the agenda and at that
this time if there's something else that
people would like to put on this let's
get it on added to it the agenda there's
a lot here
um
not seeing anything else being added but
okay great then is there a motion to
approve the agenda so okay motion made
by the senator award and second by
representative cordelli
um now we have the minutes from the
previous meeting and we had nobody
taking minutes so I wrote some minutes
up briefly on that I think we ought to
look at that and maybe if somebody wants
to take meds they're welcome to do so or
we continue to do it this way
um
you haven't had a chance to read any of
that I think everybody should take a
moment or two to read them over to see
if it's reflective or see if it really
States
some of what we discussed there's
summary notes
any any comments here
to me
I'm okay with the minutes
anything
to my right
nothing
to approve
okay you're making money okay
representatively made a motion to
approve is there second okay
um any discussion on on the minutes
all this favor
see unanimous okay so we can put the the
minutes aside
and get into the order in which we want
to address some of the issues in front
of us here today the first one I I noted
on the docket for today is Ed 306
preliminary minimum standards for public
school approval and you'll note on the
bottom of the agenda there are the dates
for the hearings that Fred bermati is
presenting regarding Ed 306 to locales
um I guess the first thing I'd like to
ask is there anybody that has attended
well I I plan on doing the last one in
Concord
but uh is there any feedback yes
representative luno
sure thanks
um thanks Rick uh Mel and I actually
attended one a few several weeks ago
over at Bow high school and um and we
were we were a little surprised about
how the um the the the presentation went
uh you know we know we know Fred
vermonte pretty well and um and I know
he's certainly committed to uh to strong
student outcomes
um uh for New Hampshire for New
Hampshire Public School students but uh
but he didn't really spend much time
talking about the proposed changes nor
what the effects would be in terms of
outcome he talked a lot about background
and maybe
um this um maybe this committee could
provide
um Mr bramonte with with some feedback
only as as
you know it looks like that that there's
um the next meeting coming up is
scheduled for June 27th and then it goes
into September and I think he was going
to have like 20 or so of these um forums
but um but you know I'm not trying to be
critical in a in a negative way but you
know in a way that I I think would be
helpful in terms of um uh disseminating
information that's material to the
proposed changes so that um so that Fred
can get the the critical feedback he's
looking for from
um you know
from people who attend these sessions
was there a lot of good input coming in
or was there not good input coming in
the the in
my perspective is it it lacked any sort
of detail on what the proposed changes
were and uh it sort of spent more time
on the background that led to the
changes or leading to the proposed
changes as opposed to what the proposed
changes are
and um and and he did get some feedback
that from from uh some members in the
audience that some people in the
audience that that sort of suggested hey
a little bit more detail on on you know
what the what the proposed changes are
would be helpful was there any
discussion regarding some of those
changes in terminology of competencies
first proficiency and Mastery no or or
expectations yeah there wasn't that type
of discussion and and Mel and I have had
conversations with with Fred one-on-one
on that Mel maybe you want it yeah
I uh followed up on that conversation
I have a conversation with Fred
following the the um
bow meeting and gave him some
suggestions on being a little more
substantive I mean Fred wants to hear
from people there's no question that's
his intent
but there was no opportunity really to
provide the kind of feedback that I
thought he was really looking for
and I gave him several suggestions on
how to open up the sessions now
subsequent to that we've gotten feedback
from some of our committee members that
went to the one in cursage
and also there was one in Keene that
followed the bow meeting
and uh my feedback we've been getting is
that it's basic hasn't changed much of
this presentation which is unfortunate
because I think this is a his goal is to
get feedback but I don't believe from
what I'm gathering he's not getting a
lot of feedback because of how he's
presenting it and I I wish that he would
um be a little more definitive on laying
out what the changes are and then
getting feedback from what he's saying
to people
I don't believe that's coming I know
Patty you were I I went to the one June
5th at Memorial and it was almost 45
minutes of a PowerPoint of why this the
history of this going back to 1995 the
things that came out in 2007
um what competencies are as opposed to
just getting pass or feel or getting
grades
um Mastery versus proficiency and then
any questions
and like nobody in the audience had been
told anything about what was in the 306
changes so there's no discussion
regarding acknowledgment versus mastery
I I had the side by side because we had
before and I asked the question about
that I was concerned with shells being
changed to Maize in May provide from
shall provide and my only answer was
it's good to be flexible
so really and and I know that he did a
presentation for the Manchester School
Board who wrote him I guess pages of
their concerns and suggestions and he
did acknowledge that but he also said
it's nice to get suggestions for changes
but you know you don't know if they're
going to happen
so
hmm
was were the sessions well attended or
um 25 in both oh okay
but it was
school board members
um you know uh
um
elected officials you know and one
person in the audience brought this is
very nice and and the way you explain
everything but if you're just a regular
old parent that's not involved in any of
this you don't know what you're talking
about we don't understand what you're
talking about at all so I mean even the
presentation of the way it is it's
presented so that people who are
involved in education can understand it
but your parent will only who has kids
going to school and that's their
involvement with education doesn't
understand this
was there any reference at all to the
you know when we have the individual
subject areas
identified within our rules be it
mathematics physical education Health
there's also elements underneath which
try to define those skills and that
knowledge that study there's a gap
that's been taken out of these rules was
there any comment regarding that
huh
I mean if if it would be nice if Fred
had the side by side because I think
that really that provides some sense of
background to what's a change whether
you agree with them or not is irrelevant
the point is this is what they are
and I think that's why when we got them
from the committee standpoint that was
very instructive to begin to look at
that and I just don't none of that and
I'm concerned because there were at
least a bow and I'm assuming that the
others there were members of the
um committee or whatever they called
themselves that created this there were
members of them there but they didn't
seem to be engaged at all in the process
and I was hoping that some of them would
be able to give further feedback to Fred
about what you needed to do to think
about this or whatever but it doesn't
seem that the basic format at least at
this point in time has really changed
that much because I did do a follow-up
on when he went to Keene he went from
Beau to King the next night and to see
if he'd made any changes in that and
from what I understand there was really
it was basically the same same
presentation
so I'm concerned I'm concerned that I
don't think he's getting what he really
I think he really is his intent is
and and Rick yeah I I think it would
also be important to
um you know during these public
um uh sessions for um for Mr bervante to
talk about
um how the flexibility that that he's
suggesting and that Patty uh referenced
how that could manifest in terms of
different versions of of public school
and um and you know to be able to meet
uh a flexible uh minimum standards uh or
be compliant with a flexible minimum
standards document and um and be able to
say well in this community public school
could look like this and in this other
community public school could look like
this and uh and and you know rather than
just using the term flexible I I think
people have
um I know I have a better uh easier time
understanding if you can sort of fit a
hypothetical into that and say well now
I see what this looks like now I see
what that could look like and uh taking
taking
um taking people through some of those
examples I think could be very helpful
how did this really impact local control
in terms of of uh my district being able
to say we're going to have 24 required
credits to get out of here first 20 here
in this one uh how how is are these new
standards proposed draft standards
laying up against that ability the the
graduation requirements set by the local
which they have the right to do now
and there's also requirements of of the
state which we've identified through
rule
um is there that flexibility being taken
or is it do you know yeah I I I don't
think that was discussed but I think
that would be a good that's an example
of a hypothetical that that I think
would would help members of the public
really understand what's being and would
help us too
um
um you know understand what's being
proposed would it help if we invite Fred
to this meeting of one of our meetings
and we have more folks here so we could
have a
I think we're more in tune with rules
every day just about we're looking at I
I think I think that makes a lot of
sense Rick I would I definitely given
given give giving him time to sort of
prepare and understand what our um
um interests are going to be in that
meeting and um
um
and I think identifying what
representative Meyer said lay out the
changes yeah
and I think what what has he found I
mean by the time we would have him come
here you might assume sometime in the
fall yeah you know what has he found
what's the feedback that he's getting
from them uh and what are some of the
suggested changes that the committee
made are you looking at as they begin to
deal with their final draft going to
look forward to it
so now it's not our requirement to we
don't approve the minimum standards of
public school approval those are
certainly School State Board of
Education responsibility
but it certainly does impact
uh I I I there may not be a direct
linkage with our our
academic standards in the subject areas
and the criteria and the substance
criteria which we have for an adequate
education but there's a linkage
and
you know I I you know I I remember when
we put health and wellness the wellness
came out of the Ed 306 and supported our
changing it in at in our uh opportunity
for an adequate education that
substantive criteria that's where we got
the word wellness and we're able to
really substantiate it because that's
what people are doing
so I think there is a linkage and I
think we have a good position to be
requesting him to come and discuss with
us
how do you feel about that I didn't even
know about these meetings so I couldn't
go to any one of them although I would
have but there's quite a few of them up
within easy driving distance yeah right
so I will have to go to the September
12th one and I think that's one of the
issues yeah I think he's had a problem
in in the advertising of these meetings
coming forward but in most cases they
would have been through a local school
newsletter or from a superintendent in
the school districts that they're in but
the actual Statewide thing there's not
been a lot of hype around right you need
to get to see these the other places you
can work so I'm sorry that I just saw
these because they have been out but
they've been not widely known well the
last one should be good because if it's
received on your input well that's why I
was expecting the last one to go to
but the rules they were last adopted
back in 2015 that's when we changed them
and every 10 years yeah
and so we're rolling in on on 2025.
so I I think that's what they're trying
to prepare for here uh
when would be a good time for us to try
you know maybe we're jumping it when
we'd have our next meeting but
if Fred's able to come we ought to try
to and give us some information
regarding these changes and what she's
getting us feedback from those schools
and side by side information I think
that'd be very helpful for us
and for him sometime in mid-september or
something okay yeah if the last one is
yeah mid-september then give him time to
or even even early October right yes
okay I'm not sure when these are are do
we know the date that they're supposed
to go to the State Board
okay I think after all of his healings
because I think what happens is that
through the state board's credit
but they did receive the uh
initial draft they basically moved to
the side for these hearings to take
place before they actually started that
60-day process
foreign
so then mid-september early October I
think would be in line to have him come
in and and do a presentation for us are
we all good with that request
good is there any need to stay on the
issue of Ed 306 at this time
no
okay uh jumping down to the next one
which we have which is civics education
and
I have
on on the the large
packet
where there's a 63 that's item 60 and
three within the hb2
and this is the language which is Pierce
in law that's underlined which
stipulates that there's going to be the
sum of one million dollars for fiscal
year ending June 30 2023 which shall not
lapse for the purpose of developing and
creating a New Hampshire Civics textbook
to be distributed to every New Hampshire
Civics classroom
so uh I'm assuming that this will
probably get signed into law
I think there's a really good chance
seeing the governor when in his
presentation has Civics as an issue that
needs to be addressed
um
so then what I've done is I've
I've
put into this packet of materials
uh information
uh starting uh see
on like page three
the results of the nape and I think
we're all very familiar with the results
nape this is information which is posted
on the doe website
that the Nationwide we did very poorly
in terms of civics education there for
hb2
so that information is available I don't
think there's necessary to get into a
lot of that that's there for your
information so jumping ahead to page
seven now I want to just explain that
within statute
and in statute is
um
uh on pay it's on it's a it's stapled to
the back side of your agenda there's 189
colon 10 says studies
uh see that's that part let's see uh
no that's all regarding the second one
um we do have it's the part that's
dealing with
maybe it's in this package awesome it's
in this set yeah it's it's on page eight
if we go to page eight that's what I'm
looking for 189 colon 11. instruction in
Nationals in State history and
government and we have in our statute
right now A through J those are areas of
study dealing with uh the United States
and New Hampshire government Civics
course at a minimum the course shall
include instruction in these a through J
areas
and this is for information the first
item there you can see opportunities and
responsibilities for civic involvement
if you look at page 10 of this document
that I have before you here this comes
out of the plan from the state of Ohio
which adopted their model social studies
curriculum in 2019. Senator Dale's
Andrew and I put these a through not J
but a through I into statute back around
2017-18 when this was still draft but
this has since been adopted by Ohio but
the Ohio has four basic strands in their
social studies program
because uh history government
geography
and economics those are the strands
within the government strand there is a
Civic involvement strand
and
you can see that the content statement
optimally specific engagement within
structures of government
are made possible through political and
public policy process and we have
occupational responsibilities for civic
involvement we modified language a
little bit but they're similar if you
went down to Item B
foreign
in the
on pages 10 through 11 B says skills to
effectively participate in civic affairs
that's what this is all about right
there
um
so we took that you know uh political
parties interest groups and me to
provide options for civic involvement
through various means that's in the Ohio
plant on D C excuse me
um it's reflected on 12 and 15. C says
the U.S Constitution principle stated in
the Articles of Amendment of the United
States Constitution that provide the
foundation of democratic government of
the United States that is right there on
pages 12 and that in that we just stole
it right directly from Ohio
and same thing for Eve we're supposed to
be talking about the structure and
function of three branches comprising
federal state governments legislative
judicial and executive if you look at
page 16 in the Ohio model
you can see it talks directly about the
three branches of government
another thing we just took from that
state they had put their model together
with with
Consultants with teachers with people
teaching it in with various associations
it was a task force put together to
develop this curriculum that they have
and then uh going on down to the next
one
F the role opportunities and
responsibilities of citizens to engage
in Civic activity if you go to page 18
you can see that there it says in the
United States people have the rights to
protect them from undue government
interference rate rights carry
responsibilities to help Define how
people use the rights and require
respect for the rights of others
um and they they talking about
engagement
and that's item number 15 in their
content statement
so we took that one as well
um on G where it says the role of
interactions the state of New Hampshire
and local governments within framework
of the United States Constitution
obviously we didn't take Ohio's because
but they do have that on page 1920 we
just have written in New Hampshire that
we want to be also teaching about Civics
on the local level and the state level
and which is on H the how federal state
and local governments address problems
and issues making decisions creating
this and you can see item 20 Page 21
they also have that as
um individuals and organizations play a
role within federal state and local
governments and helping determine public
domestic and foreign policy
um and it speaks to it a little bit down
below on item 20 in theirs as well and
also uh the last one I the rule in the
actions of government and the flow of
economic activity and regulation of
monetary policy that came specifically
uh on on theirs on page 22 you can see
the Federal Reserve System uses monetary
too is to regulate the nation's monetary
Supply and moderate the effects of
expansion and Contra contraction in the
economy and they talk about the the feds
in the in that system
so so we took this now I also took a
little bit of time and went through and
say okay what are they doing in terms of
civics education for all the grades and
they have taken and you can see on page
children continue to build on their
understanding of chronological timelines
and calendars that are introduced in
grade two
um
this is the grade one social studies
curriculum which they had in Ohio and
every grade level seems to they carve
out Civics within government
and it's something that maybe we ought
to be looking at when we're developing a
textbook I know it's uh not our
responsibility do that I didn't
understand within hb2 where it says the
Department of Education colon
commissioner Commission on New Hampshire
civics
Commission on New Hampshire Civics what
can who's on that Commission
I've never heard of it
that was
that's New Hampshire Civics I don't know
if it's a commission
that's a non-profit yeah
so I don't know who's going to be
writing this thing uh appropriate to the
Department of commission New Hampshire
Civics established in RSA 21nhc I went
and looked at there is no 28 1C
unless it's in hb2 somewhere
um
some of the million bucks
so I you know so in writing this thing I
think it's important that because this
is going to impact our responsibility
for oversight on this area which is
within an adequate education
yeah
on um the executive director of New
Hampshire Civics uh has has resigned a
Martha Madsen and she's left they've got
they do have an interim uh acting there
so that's and that organization
primarily deals a lot with the social
studies teachers Etc the other thing is
is that there is an organization
that's uh
I've been tangentially uh
in contact with and that is they're
working on Civics and civility
which is dealing with the primary
election and again uh Mr bramante has
been the key uh factor in that and it's
the the design of that is to try to do
exactly what this is doing only from a
political standpoint as far as the
election goes it's a bipartisan effort
to engage students not only in this
state but across the country actually
to be engaged in the primary election
but there's a whole program that they're
developing that's a lot of this content
that's here Rick that leads up to the
primary election where students from
across the region and across the country
can get involved in this and
um they're moving right along and
they've got sponsors and they're
developing they're developing
programs curriculum that would provide
engagement of students in this process
that with the culmination of it
basically being engaging with candidates
that are running for uh the presidential
primary uh presidential election
but those are just two things that
directly relate to the Civic stuff the
the reason why I bring this topic up if
you look on the agenda on the back side
there's some statutory language on page
two of the agenda there
and it's 193 E2 Dash a substantive
educational content of an adequate
education so Civics is listed under four
so
um it's our responsibility I see these
as
standards of what we teach academic
standards subject areas
correctly if I'm mistaken but so then
somehow
if we're getting down and we're now
going to be contracting out somebody to
do I have no problem with that I have no
problem with other groups getting
involved and writing this but they've
always come back for approval they have
to come back for approval by the state
board and the state board but if it
comes to academic standards the
legislative oversight company is
responsible for reviewing and
recommending
correct me if I'm wrong in that one no I
think I think no I think that's right
out of the statute that's right on the
Statue I I do have a question though
with respect to
um page eight
um
part h
which is um which you've got reference
to uh the Ohio
um page 132 which is 21 at page 21 in
this packet I'm not quite sure I'm
seeing the the the the direct reference
to Ohio's plan
as it as it relates to how federal state
and local governments address problems
and issues by making decisions creating
laws enforcing regulations and taking
action
because that's sort of the the
um
the the the the full
I'm not I'm not trying to say we need to
be using Ohio at all no no say I'm just
trying to show that this is the
historical background of how we got to
what we did right right but and I and I
think having a having a model from
another state is sort of helpful when
when looking at how you go about
defining
um you know you know these these various
academic standards in a way that that
doesn't take a a partisan you know
um sweat because Civics can sort of
easily easily you know fall into that
trap and um and H I think is
particularly interesting because it
basically references how the three
branches of of government operate
um to address problems and issues by
making decisions
executive creating laws legislative
enforcing regular regulations executive
and taking action that would be a
combination of executive and judicial
um and be great if Ohio had had
something that sort of spoke to uh
um
yeah see they talk about the the those
the three branches at all levels
addressing public policy issues that
arise domestic International that's on
page page 20.
um
21 talks about more of like the Public's
ability that you engage in government
yeah
um at the top of the top of page 21 and
then 19 yes I'm looking at it yeah
and then 20 that the bottom of page 21
number 20
um seems to be more of a um
legislative policy
yeah explain how the federal government
but not how the government addresses
problems yes yeah right yeah and issues
and yeah
and obviously I think that's a that's a
big thing is what we're seeing play out
with the news from last week too and I'm
not trying to make it make it political
here but but you know it doesn't help
when when people get up and say you know
the weaponization of the Department of
Injustice
and that doesn't help
well I think we're just going to have to
it that that's hopefully what we would
do with a good Civics program as we
would
teach people about Civics and how to
engage and try to get resolution in a
meaningful lasting memory so
I I I you know I know there's a lot of
different Civics programs out there but
I'm just wanting to just try to figure
out
Commission in the okay from the budget
so that was in hp2 yeah the commission's
in there has like the textbook stuff
like an excerpt
thank you Jim
okay
it's just assassinated into the book
here yeah well yeah it's it's yeah I was
looking at one section hp2 is another
section this part right here on the
other side of it
it's interesting that this
um also talks about the textbook
um and even a paper copy of the textbook
whereas
um correct me if I'm wrong Senator Ward
but there was a lot of discussion
um about this textbook during the Senate
budget hearings there was um an
amendment put forward by Senator
D'Alessandro to cut the one million
dollars
because he didn't think that a textbook
was actually required and I think the
um other side of that coin that Senator
Bradley talked about was that it didn't
necessarily have to be a a paper text
but but could be digital
um because there were concerns about the
cost of doing a hard copy textbook and
distributing to all the schools and
everything else
um so I think that that's a a question
that will play out as we go forward in
terms of the million dollars and what
kind of textbook we are actually looking
at producing
there was a lot of discussion and I
think with it if you have a digital book
you can go in easily and make the
changes whereas with a printed book you
have to you know reprint it and
redistribute it
so I attended that meeting on that
Friday afternoon Friday that when
Finance
that's the one where Senator gray and
Senator Bradley etc etc and then Senator
dalessandro and and and Cindy were there
um it's it's
um
I can remember Senator Lou D'Alessandro
questioning okay if we're going to have
a textbook
who's going to print it you know who all
the costs associated with it uh who's
gonna write it uh and he was advocating
for uh the people that are the social
studies teachers organizations
Etc to be contributors
to this process and when it was cut to a
million dollars
then he he said well I don't know if
we're going to be able to do it for a
million bucks if we're talking about
everybody the 160 000 kids
with a textbook and of course and one
textbook's not going to be good for you
know grade six and grade
10 or 11. there's different contents in
terms of civics and how you present it
and topics and and and it has to be a
scope and sequence type Affair uh so I
think he was coming from his perspective
of being a social studies teacher and
and he alluded to other flying folks of
what he has had in his classes and that
he has taught
and he he said that
um
i i i i he likes he's he's a textbook
person
but I I think that when then the
commissioner spoke out and said well we
can do this digitally with a million
dollars and trying to I think even try
to protect the money for the whole
program
so it's it's an issue which I think is
still up in the I know you see a written
copy here but I I'm confused on that
myself I've gone through this process I
did it for the state of Maine
and we we had a textbook
for
the Civics in the fourth grade
and because that was our where we taught
main studies and we had Civics and and
families you know knowing this 70
dollars you have this which you can
afford to spend and the kids learn that
concept
then in the middle school there was a
not a textbook there was teacher's guide
with a lot of opportunity for activities
which should be pursued showing the
goals the objectives of the program
and where the resources were available
and then we did the same thing for
specific courses within the high school
for the lower grades there is only a
book for grades
two three and four and later on at the
upper end of the elementary school
so I I think that we need to really
filter through this and find out just
how this is going to be done and we
ought to have some input on that too
because there's nobody on this
you imagine
that from the legislation
two members of the house okay one in the
Senate
so Rick yeah on the um on what you
started talking about on the the
hb2 page 18 of what what Jen just handed
out line eight for the purpose of
creating a New Hampshire Civics Tech
textbook to be distributed dot dot dot
um is is
part of the question here what that
means could could that be interpreted as
K-12 curriculum
you know you know grade appropriate or
for um or skill appropriate
um
curriculum uh that could be you know
that that serves as a
serves as the curriculum used in in all
public schools
I don't think there's a hard definition
of civics textbook to be distributed
here so
um
because I agree with what Senator Ward
was saying and what representative
cordelli was saying that that you know
what your uh what you're putting in
front of a fourth grader is you know
potentially quite different from what
you're putting in front of a 11th grader
it says to every New Hampshire Civics
classroom was that
I'm going to look at it it's a Civics
classroom doesn't mean High School
well there's a required course in civics
so is that the one they're talking about
the text so the print of copy will be in
each classroom but not necessarily to
each child that's how I see this
but I think the intent here
was to create
an ongoing
really K-12 program
with varying varying components of it uh
that's age age specific
and so I mean you know for example I
remember I think somebody was talking
about like in in the lower elk grades
the mere fact of doing some
collaborative decision making
is part of a Civics initiative of how do
you make decisions how do you solve
problems that is that's a that's a
that's a component it's not a government
issue but it's a it's a dealing with the
Civility and the and and how do you
engage in decision making so I think I
would hope the commission would begin to
look at not just a textbook
but what kinds of activities and what
kinds of curriculum that's available
throughout the Spectrum uh depending
upon what the uh age level of the
student happens to be so every year
you're not just dealing with a fourth
grade program but every year there's
something that's going to be engaging
the students in some kind of a Civics
activity
well it says create a textbook and
related curriculum exactly right the
related curriculum I think that's what's
critical here
and I think the the whole issue of of
online stuff is important too because in
this in this program there's a lot of
video that's available
that could also be used that's not
printed material I'm not downgrading
printed material but uh with with how
youth today is so engaged in the video
world
it would seem to me that that has got to
be part of an under a foundational piece
of the program
video of Martin Luther King's I Have A
Dreams Music right yeah
we have for example I I was sharing with
Martha Madsen now those of us that had
worked on the 18 year old vote we now
have a uh 55-minute video that basically
talks about how we how those of us that
were involved in this thing organized it
lobbied it and then engaged in the uh
the whole voter registration and I mean
I I think she's going to be using that
with her social studies groups and they
have their annual meeting in the fall so
I mean it's that kind of activity I
think that that's important
okay
so uh
I think that the primary thing I try to
achieve today I think I've done that is
that where it where our current language
came from it came from basically
from Ohio now um where we go I guess
it's up to that Commission
and I think one of your set one of the
uh one of the assessments will be
the next time when we hit the get the
curriculum going here you'll be able to
see whether or not there's an
improvement in the uh
results of the test scores on this
well that that goes to the the other
question I think I had listed there
um somewhere in that um
there's accountability
now how to measure Improvement and
assessment under 5A on the agenda is
that going to be locally developed or is
that going to be something which is
developed by that Commission
so um
so I think something that's important to
reference on this too is the the Doe's
news release which you've got copied on
page three yeah
um and it it goes to say that uh
Nationwide
average scores declined in the uh in in
U.S history and Civics for eighth
graders compared to 2018 with Civic
scores declining for the first time
since the assessment began in 1998
and so this is specific to the 2022 nape
and obviously there's a lot going on in
in the 2020 2021 and 2022 uh nape uh you
know because of coven and
I think under would would one of the uh
objectives of the commission also be to
understand what
um
what contributed to the decline in um
which which clearly
um bucks the trend
that of of improving improved results
since the beginning of assessment back
in 1998
I mean was it curriculum was it covid
was it
something else
it's hard to tell from these nape
scores here I'd like to find out what's
going on in their own State yeah yeah
well I mean the the nape score is
tracked by track to the state too so we
could see how New Hampshire did on this
not just Nationwide averages
and the states never really been
in the business of an assessment for
social studies we haven't been doing
that that's been relegated to the local
and then we have well we're going to
assess the performance based upon the
immigration test
and and of course there's also within
our statute the provision
I don't know if I even put that Statute
in here
where there's a local local competency
test for social studies also offered
um
see um
I think I may not have put that yeah
let's see wait a minute
yeah it says right here on page nine
as a component instruction or paragraph
one locally developed competency
assessment of the United States
government and Civics that includes but
it's not limited to
um
I've never seen any of those results
uh is it possible for this group
for us to even find out how we're doing
on that locally developed assessment and
what is their developed competency
assessment how that has that being done
in schools for I don't know if it's
being done or not
is that local assessment uh sent on to
the department
it's not specified in there it doesn't
look like
that last sentence
yeah
yeah that's just the immigration that's
the immigration test but but not local
but we don't know how they're doing on
their local competency tests for social
studies
but if they take the immigration test
they don't also have to take the other
one so they may not true so that might
skew the results right too
so it's either
we talked about local you talk about
local thin State when we talk about each
municipality
each district each district yep it's
School District yeah
foreign
shall be administered to students
as part of the required High School
course
in history and government
we're is it possible to find out how
students are doing
on that locally developed assessment
we we gave this authority to these
school districts when we said it's no
longer a Statewide assessment
that was back early on under uh Jenny
Berry
I have a meeting with with Melissa white
of the department on Wednesday so I
could ask her
about it at that point
yeah whether they are familiar with this
or got any information provided to them
if not I'd even just like to see what
those locally developed assessments look
like
I only see the results I just like to
see what they that'd be good for that
commission to have a beat on it
I think accountability is really
important we oftentimes put money into
doing something but we
we don't get the results whether it
makes any difference or not
is the committee's support of our put a
request into the department to see if
they can acquire if they don't have this
locally accepted locally developed
assessments so we can see them have them
available
I'd like to see it I would yeah
okay
so we will ask that
I'm having a hard time finding the
civics
nape data
state level and and I hear you speaking
about the nape data for civics is that
broken down by state I'm trying to it
must be yeah at least for other subjects
I'm not sure yeah but I'm just not
finding it on Civics yeah I've seen it
on on the other subjects
and and looking at the Department's you
know a more you know closer read of the
Department's Short news release here
it's it's referencing Nationwide Trends
not which you know
which aren't necessarily reflective of
Statewide trends
I can also be interesting to see if they
receive all these
reports from the school districts by
June 30.
we're right there
it's always an issue isn't it yeah
it's probably just like the uh emergency
operation plans 20 came in yeah
no sense writing this stuff in the law
so so could we ask the department for um
for the for the Statewide
um so if those are available yeah yeah
Statewide Nate yeah or no no I'm sorry
not Statewide
um by by District yeah they'll ask for
the local tests yeah okay ask for the
state nape results right and ask for you
know the citizenship and Immigration
Services tab
so there's three things we're requesting
on out of this law in in as granular uh
you know we should be able to get it
right down to the I mean we don't need
Student data but we need um District
data
yeah and if and if it can be
I mean the nape data on a national basis
is is also
um
categorized by uh what's the what's the
term
um disaggregated
groups did I get that right yeah by like
different subgroups like so for yeah
yeah and if that's available yeah
um by District
okay
I want to do is I'll I'll write a letter
and see see if everybody on the
committee here
on the commission committee and and send
it to the
the commissioner also to the state board
board
that's good
that'd be great yeah and I'll get that
done right after this
okay
any more discussion on the on the civics
H9 okay we'll get that done that'll help
us so we're we're going to write this
letter we also have the request of Fred
bermonti for late September
mid-september October let's let's go on
to the next item on our docket here uh
which is down below under Mental Health
um I think this needs a some some
discussion
um
when I get
here
uh okay where are we
under our current
um
Ed rules Ed
306.40 Under health education program so
that's attached to your agenda I'm
looking at the back page
it has listed mental health under 2G
see that
okay so that's listed as a component of
our health education program
not as a separate
my question is is that and we'll have to
know this because we have retained three
bills
are we going to go try to put this in
the area studies like we've done other
components of Health and Wellness or are
we going to insert it in as a
requirement of adequacy as a separate
because it diverges it from how we've
addressed it as a state in the past it's
been a component underneath
yeah and I I quite honestly
I don't have a clear understanding what
is mental
mental
um
I why I bring this up today I'm fearful
of one thing is when I was teaching as a
principal back in the 70s 80s 90s we had
an issue which was I think came to
everybody's attention ADHD
and what do we do with this attention
deficit disorder which is a hyperactive
for some of the kids were always on the
jig really moving around and all uh I I
had my own youngster like that and and
so what was the thing that the school
off time said put him on Ritalin yeah
we had so many kids on Ritalin
and Young Rick we found out later his IQ
is over 140. and this kid was
supercharged up here in the head and was
you know just very active and sometimes
very bored and and so I don't want to go
down the route of having
mental health being a
identified by folks which aren't
properly trained to do that the doctor
the psychologists maybe the school
counselor
um certainly I as a teacher was not
prepared to do that uh I often spoke to
special ed people because you start
getting at the area of of IEP
so we have within these bills
that desire on one of them is to have a
comprehensive mental health program I
don't know what quite that means I think
we retained because there was some
concern as definition whether it should
be placed into adequacy or put
underneath studies I agree there seems
to be issues going on in our schools
right now I hear from so many
Professionals in the field
but there was a lot of discussion about
ADHD too
and that's where we went with that
um and we started prescribing things and
discussing things
that I don't think I had the expertise
to be discussing
so I I opened that up for a discussion
right now
where we're going to go on it
I think that that you touched on special
education I think some of that
mental health what
what aspects of mental health qualify
you for an IEP and special education
um the government just
defined HD HD as
um an issue that would qualify you for
idea
what other things
are we going down a path where maybe in
some cases where over
qualifying students for special
education over identifying students for
special education because of
you know maybe anxiety or something else
you know I that's something I'm
interested in also
I can remember my school psychologist I
had when I was a young principal back in
Gardner Maine
and in those days we were just coming
into idea
and
we were talking about Behavior
those versed in emotional handicapping
condition and there there's a difference
there
which is environment behavior Can
oftentimes be a result of something
negative going on at home or how the the
student is feeling and so you see
negative behaviors which are contrary to
what we want to see as the norm
but is that truly an IEP
handicapping condition I was told it
wasn't that it was something that could
be supported through
you know
almost like a a plan to help that
particular child it didn't have to be
done through Special Ed I don't know
that I was even thinking of these builds
as as having to do with special
education or just more like kids being
able to identify how they're feeling and
and saying okay I'm feeling really
anxious today or or if it's okay to feel
like that if you're feeling it about
something or or I'm really sad and that
you know and being able to talk to
somebody about why am I feeling sad or
or I don't know if I if I was I did if I
was
putting those bills in a special
education category I didn't see them as
as not necessarily special ed but is it
it's a part of adequacy or is it part of
Health which should be putting what you
got but change the statutory reference
to studies
that's that's I guess where where we put
uh studies is in the sheet right there
and that's where we're talking about
let's see which which one am I listening
here
um yeah the school board shall ensure
the health education physical education
to include importance of exercise and
wellness are taught the pupils as part
of
um
to include physiology hygiene Health
interpersonal relationships physical
education
oppositional to put what you just
discussed in where we have the other
components of Health I I just don't want
to develop another
another category within the the
substantive criteria for an adequate
education
that's I think where one of the bills
lays it out to be in that area
whereas it's more appropriate to stick
language that you're proposing over
underneath studies
189 10.
so
um Rick I know we've we've um in fact
the the language in 189 10
shows amendments that were made over the
last I think couple of Cycles with the
um uh with interpersonal relationships
and the personal finance literacy
yeah yeah and it also has things like
abuse of children human interactions I
think that would that have been maybe
AIDS but but but I think you know above
Romans 1 and 2 and 3 is Roman one
um which talks about the Department of
Education shall survey school districts
um biennially to receive reports on
compliance with this section
and I'm not I I don't know if this is
the whole section
um but I'm sure compliance with Roman 2
and Roman 3.
and um do we have copies of those
reports from
prior
biennium
and I'm sort of wondering if the study
isn't what students are studying but
what we're studying
how school districts are responding to
uh Roman 2 and Roman 3.
when I talked with uh
Anthony Anthony's no longer with us
um he's retired he he said that we are
we haven't really defined what that
category 189 verse 193 right
are we sometimes we're loading up one
when we shouldn't be loading up that
when we should be loading the other one
up and really clarify ourselves as to
where we want to put these concentrated
studies that are within these criteria
that are not identified in 193 where
should we put those
and he was always suggesting to me
Pullman 189 that's where we need to list
this stuff seeing that you have in your
rules where mental health is part of
your health right and so you've you've
got you've under 193e you've got seven
which is health and wellness and 10
which is personal financial literacy so
those correspond to Roman 2 and Roman
three of one that 189 10 and 2 and 3
clearly build out what it's what is
meant by health and what is meant by
personal financial literacy
um so maybe it's a maybe it's a good
place to provide greater
I don't know detail
on what the legislator legislature is
looking for and also to get a um to get
a report
do you know in you're looking at 8306
rules because that's where all this
stuff that we're looking at here appears
in the 300 series
are these areas which specify like I
pointed on the back side of that sheet
where it talks about alcohol and drug
injury prevention nutrition physical
activity Family Life tobacco mental
health Etc are those being scratched
from the new proposed rules
is that the Gap Elements which are
there's the Gap that uh the school
boards Association addressed
it maybe I yeah among other things I
think we got to be careful because if
we're losing it here then we've got to
make sure it's somewhere else
and we we ought to be putting it
underneath where we have all the rest of
the health stuff and really load up the
health section and do it properly
um
what's included within health and
wellness yeah so so could we actually
could we ask the department for the um
for maybe the last
I don't know three reports
that this section requires
the department has a whole department of
of Health and Wellness that should have
all of this and and I our school
district's supposed to be doing
something with mt SSB however they want
to do it I know Manchester has two
directors of Mt SSB but I actually don't
even know what they what they do right
but I know they have them so I I I think
there's something going on everywhere
but we just don't know what it is but I
I think the department there is is
pretty much on top of that because I've
spoken to somebody there before and she
knew everything that was going on
in all the different places and I can't
remember would you know I can't remember
what her name is
uh okay
or they might not okay I'd go uh Dave
you know it says at the top the
department shell surveys School District
biannually
um
I'd go back 10 years oh I'm and so we
get five reports and so you go back
prior to covid
and so your your reports were gonna
somebody's going to say well that's just
related to covet uh let's let's go back
as far as we can get well I absolutely
agree yeah yeah I think my concern is
that
I think the interest in this area
has been spiked
as you've come out of covert
as we begin to see that there are a lot
of students
who are still reacting
to their isolation during that period of
time I mean we've done a lot of good
work in the state dealing with special
ed special ed referrals Etc
that is not my interest in this area
because I do think there's a new
interest
that deals with how are we dealing with
students who are struggling because I
mean we heard reports of
the lack of maturation on the part of
some students that like 8th graders are
really behaving at a sixth grade access
grade level
and so my concern is what are the
support systems in trying to ramp up I
mean how long I don't know the answer to
this question how long does it take a
student or a young person who has been
disen who's been disengaged from a
social interactions with students where
they are would ordinarily have been
maturing
didn't during that two period two-year
period of Time how long does it take and
what does it take to get them up to I
want to say grade level but up to their
age level if you may that they're
behaving in a way that that they should
be behaving and I that so as I look at
this area here notwithstanding what
we've talked about as far as reports Etc
what are the systems that are in place
or need to be in place in school
districts to expedite
the students maturation to their age
level I guess that's a way to put it so
that that really is my concern as I look
at this
at this and that's not necessarily
what's the curriculum that's going to do
it but what are the experiences that
would help them expedite their
maturation so that's that's kind of
where I am on this particular topic
well if we get if we get any reports
that they have going back at least can
you give us an idea yeah that will give
us some basic information which is
necessary
um
I'm going to kind of believe that you
know in my discussions with our
superintendent we're on other health
impaired category IP has grown
I just by
observing
students there there's there's there is
there's a change I'm great I watched a
graduation at the elementary school it
was a k through eight just the other
night and and I watched it the previous
year too
there was a different field this year
because I think what's Just Happening
we're seeing some of that catch up
happening and developing
um and I do believe that teachers
working real hard to try and get that
to that level I see it I saw it with
their band and choral program it was
really just outstanding and it was
and of course you ever you know as a
teacher every three years you get a crop
of kids or maybe are not the ones that
you think are exemplary and that happens
that's that's that's been going on for
years yeah
um and so
I used to have teachers who used to like
take that one year to go out and get
some training on the year that could
happen was coming through
um so I I agree I think we need to have
mental health as part of and notice
somewhere underneath our health and
wellness program but I say it like that
not as a separate program I think by
saying it separately I think
it may get us into some territory we
don't want to get into is the teacher
now responsible for mental health as I
perceive it and as I Define it versus
how you see it Dave and how you define
it they may be different but clearly
it's part of Health yeah it's clearly
part of I mean physical health and
mental health yeah yeah can provides
Health yeah yeah it's just like within
the social studies we talk about we have
geography every history of government
you have Civics those are elements
within
I I I I guess I'm cautious in saying
perhaps we shouldn't try to keep these
individual elements as a separate entity
in itself as just trying to do like we
did we still call it social studies but
we have parentheses out beside it what
are those elements within that's what we
should be doing
I think with our health and wellness
and I think using the word sometimes
mental throws everything off
um because it's not so much mental
health it's your overall good health
it's part of that so I think when we say
mental health we immediately think of
you know identifying kids or them having
to go for whatever and that and that's
not necessary it's not necessarily that
it's it's just you know just good health
overall
health and wellness health and wellness
describes it pretty well but but but
just just using those words alone I
don't think does because because I think
traditionally we've we've looked at
Health as being a physical thing I mean
when you look at health insurance
um it it only up until recently has it
has it really started to look at Health
above the neck and and uh and in many
cases it still doesn't include you know
teeth or eyes or stuff like that I mean
it's sort of like everything the neck
and blow was was well understood and we
have hospitals and doctors and things
but pretty much from the neck above
you're on your own at least had been for
a long time and um and so I think as as
as we we understand that mental health
is so important to to your overall
health including yeah I think the way
they had it and
306 or whatever part this is 300
306.40
they have mental health listed as part
of the K-12
it's a component of it's like a chapter
Within
and only it's it's
it transcends all the chapters uh so I
think that we I'd like to see us hold to
the way we've been doing it but
incorporate it into and even if we feel
necessary I'm I can support it to even
list it underneath the the studies where
we have health and wellness listed we we
can put this this component Define it
right a little bit there uh rather than
putting it as a new section of an
adequate education I think that's where
we're going to have a lot of reverse on
yeah yeah I think I think and and I
think you know building it out the way
you've got it and the way it is in in
the 306 is where it does yeah um you
know specifically column maybe you know
it does specifically mention mental
health but maybe with a little bit more
detail uh behind it uh you know as this
hasn't been updated in 10 years
Frameworks which are guidance to our
school districts anymore
so the rules are the only place people
can walk to right now and see some of
these elements within these those
subject subject areas if we take it out
of 306
there's not going to be anything right
right and and and something that I
think's you know directly related to to
G and I'm not an expert in this so I'm
I'm this you know this is hopefully it's
somewhat correct is there's been a lot
of discussion
certainly when I was on a school board
but I think we've had discussion around
this committee too in terms of adverse
childhood experiences and how that
contributes to to mental health and
probably having some language in there
that that
you know speaks to the importance of
understanding
what what those are
you know and how that's impacted a
student and
yeah I know I I've gone through that
with my own grandkids sure sometimes you
say suck it up but they don't if that's
a real hard thing for a kid do when
they're being throttled every day right
and so
I think this is a very important topic
I don't want to you know throw it aside
I'm not doing that I'm just trying to
make sure we do it properly so when we
when we do talk about
um this in Greater detail could we could
we get some folks in from maybe Holly
Stevens from Nami and um
maybe even consult with Senator Whitley
on on
I'd like to get some suku School
psychologists in here and counselors in
here too and and a nurse
you're a nurse
a pediatric nurse yeah right we can have
the person who just got the school nurse
of the Year award
yeah I think that's important as well if
there's someone at the department too
that's running the yeah I'd like them to
tell us what's going on they they know
what's going on Statewide she sent me a
chart it was it actually was going out
here or do we want to do that in the
subcommittee which we're going to be
putting together that's right that's my
question
what I try to do is just get some
clarification here and I think I've
gotten that that the direction we ought
to take today that's given the direction
which we can give the subcommittee
exactly
yeah we shouldn't be duplicating there
paying three bills dealing with mental
health so we could get a better bead of
how to handle it it's James
the proposed changes for 306 change that
say the school board may require so they
could leave it out if they want to if
it's worded that way
that'd be on a side by side where Fred
comes here I think we can address all
this stuff I have a question
um we just talked about getting reports
on the last 10 years and you pointed out
that that was biennials there'll be five
reports
but then it says here on the third
sentence that the report
shall be sent to the president of the
Senate Speaker of the House of
Representative chairpersons of the
Senate and House committees with
jurisdictional education so did Rick did
you ever get a report on this
I can honestly say yay or nay on that I
do get reports I got the bullying report
I got the suspension expulsion report
um
see they oftentimes come in in the
summertime and they walk in this line
your desk there and so
he oftentimes
have to request them again okay and so I
think that's what we need to do we need
to request and get a mail did you ever
get up
long time ago that's a long time ago
that's right exactly right it's not
something that is sent on a regular
basis that we all know about
they they do send reports to us
a lot of times they come in during the
summer months and it's just left on a
desk and then what happens is that
change in leadership change in party
different chairs and and so okay that
all happens okay
so if they're a staff we should be able
to get copies done yeah that's right it
should be available we will find that
out that was my question yeah we will
find out
and those reports should also
reports that come here should also go to
the study committee yes yes yes we'll
direct them of course everybody will get
a copy of everything we get coming back
to us here
so
is there any further discussion on on
this topic
that's all we had on the docket for
today
um
so
so we're going to adjourn to a time to
be announced at some later date yeah and
we know we'll have something
mid-september or October good
okay all right Sarah good okay anything
further
all in favor of a journey all right hi
good we're out of here
it's 11 30. good
you have a meeting at 12 didn't you yeah
no I wanted one uh no we yeah we got one
back at one that's three guys yeah right
that that school building Aid one is
is an important meeting we got Amy Clark
come out from doe for that okay what is
that it's right here
yes
okay